good luck you know Rupert guys have
underestimated me my entire life and for
years I never understood why I used to
really bother me but then one day I was
driving my little boy to school and I
saw this quote by Walt Whitman it was
painted on the wall there it said be
curious not judgmental I like that
so I'll get back in my car and I'm
driving to work and all of a sudden it
hits me
all them fellas used to belittle me a
single one of them I'm curious you know
they thought they had everything all
figured out so they judged everything
and they judged everyone and I realized
that they're underestimating me who I
was had nothing to do with it because if
they were curious they would ask
questions questions like have you played
a lot of darts Ted
which I would have answered
yes sir